hi everyone my name's Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen I set up
a poll on my Twitter asking what you
wanted me to see the original Planet of
the Apes Scott Pilgrim or lethal weapon
and Scott Pilgrim won like nobody's dish
I also haven't seen Hot Fuzz and I'd
world and the other one I thought I
would start off with Scott Pilgrim since
it's a standalone thing taking a selfie
for the tweet
give me those Scott Pilgrim predictions
for the next 20 minutes
hashtag Tamra's ever seen with a picture
of me I'm very excited about this I know
nothing about Scott Pilgrim except that
it's very stylized there's a comic about
it I'm pretty sure I'm thinking that I'm
really going to enjoy this so I'm going
into this very excited to see the film
also I've been meaning to do this
because it just would go so effortlessly
into my new intro so
[Music]
okay I enjoyed so much of this film it
wasn't quite as much of a homerun
personally as baby driver was I didn't
think that the relationship between
Scott and Ramona was well enough
established for him to be risking his
life I also know I haven't seen enough
films for me to be like obsessed with
Edgar right but like I am obsessed with
Edgar right right right up front the the
room stretching scene right before it
shows Scott still pilgrim Scott Pilgrim
it's just so good and so weird we
stylized and I really enjoyed it as the
credits are going i see the cast roll
across the screen and there are a lot of
people in this that I really like Anna
Kendrick Bree Larson
Chris Evans Aubrey Plaza Audrey Aubrey
Parks and Rec also her twitter handle is
like something like eight people hag on
Twitter so good I love her well I don't
like though Scott Pilgrim I don't like
his character it's really difficult for
me to get into a film I've said this
before on this series difficult for me
to get into a character the lead
character when he is injured he does
redeem himself at the end
I love the redemption scene he's like
gaining points and lives but I don't
understand why any of the women's that
are with him in this show in this movie
would be with him he's a jerk but
literally other than the main character
I am into everyone else there's a scene
where he sees Ramona flowers for the
first time and it is so great he gets
distracted and he's coping from scene to
scene to scene and he'll get like jolted
out of his distraction and it's just so
well done now like always it's cool and
then he gets to jolt it out and he's
like oh no he's at van practice because
she jolted I was like oh no he's at this
party it's so fun I also love when he's
trying to figure out who Ramona Flowers
is and he shows a picture of her to this
guy and he's like
ramona flowers tamara shavers I love
Ramona flowers such an interesting
character her only flaw is that she
falls first Scott Pilgrim who is a loser
sorry sorry I got it my hot take on
Booker also he's still dating knives
which first of all great name
second of all cutie patootie at times a
million
especially I love when she cuts her hair
and puts blue in it she is stunning and
she needs to break up with her he
finally does but I hate that he you know
does stuff with Ramona of a4 break it's
a terrible situation and out of nowhere
there at battles abandoned Scott's band
who I dig Matthew Patel I dig his name
is the first of the evil exes shows up
and it is so weird it is show so weird
it goes into kind of like a Bollywood
like video game fight and it is out of
nowhere and I love the video game aspect
of it so much I love gaming super into
that she's an awkward guy that Matthew
Patel super odd character I love the
extremities in the evil exes could Chris
Evans comes in with his crazy eyebrows I
really enjoy that it's seven evil exes
and Scott keeps saying you're seven evil
exes she's like just axes actually love
it love it
red makes you cracked then Roxy shows up
and I didn't know her name yet she says
prepare to die now obviously she's
definitely my favorite of the exes who
all knew Elvis couldn't love her
obviously everyone knows we love her so
whatever fine then Todd the vegan
another great character
I love the vegan please it's so funny
this part of the movie is really just
about the exes coming in back to her
life and and fighting Scott there's
something missing for me and I just
think I just don't find him engaging
Michael that's I think he's amazing and
Arrested Development I loved you know so
much I think he's great in that I don't
find his personality to be maybe strong
enough to carry the I don't know I did
it doesn't work throughout the whole
movie really I just feel very bad for
knives and I loved him
holy crap I love Kim the redheaded
drummer yet the Roxy fights amazing I
said I'm a little bi furious too girl
and you get the twins which are very
forgettable I forgot about them until I
just read that Gideon great actor I love
that guy I just don't care enough about
Scott and Ramona's relationship to care
at all that she's worth getting him no
but then it gets it to the leveling out
scene and the redemption scene and he
fights for himself when he apologizes to
Kim and and he owns up to his mistakes
with knives and and that moment was
great he was likable from there on out
for me
the negative Scott appears because that
was kind of weird he ends up with Ramona
which makes sense and they just kind of
walk off Missy and I was so into the
entire film go into the fun core penis
weirdness I just I didn't like the main
character and it's pretty hard to get
over I thought that this was a
universally praised
film but when I put up the poll on
Twitter I have a really mixed review a
lot of people were just like so into it
and then a lot of people were like that
movie's moving garbage not good not
enjoyable I definitely don't think it
was not enjoyable or garbage but I I do
think there were problems whereas baby
driver I don't care what problems all
you all have dug up I just think that
movie is damn near perfect it's so good
and so I think I think I kind of went
into it just expecting that and where I
saw that it was the same person who
directed both obviously he's got this
craziness that I just love
they were different movies of course um
but I think I wish I wish Michael Cera
wasn't either cast in the role or or or
they would have made him less shitty as
a person you'll want more of the only
female ex and side IVA it was just a
sexy phase thing sit I don't need any
more predictions that was nailed it yes
yes very true I also thought it was near
that's the only ex that Ramona thought
was a girl as well the girl I hate when
oh and people like like six girls on
each other kind of gets under my skin
Scott's relationship with knives will
creep you out you'll feel really bad for
her yeah I just feel so bad for her
there were moments in the film when I
forgot that she was 17 and then I would
remember and I'd be like oh love the
nega Scott battle week week now I'm
thinking that I just missed something
consider what did I miss
I don't understand a negative school you
will admire each and every hair color
that Ramona sport and probably want to
go vegan for psychic powers I loved her
hair colors I'm trying to rock them all
right now and actually I have been doing
like a cleanse thing I've been vegan for
a couple days now and I don't have
psychic powers yet just a craving for
chicken you will be bleeping in the
video just like Julie powers oh fuck I
should have done that and think about it
you like the side characters and
villains better than the main characters
Wallace needs his own movie Wallace is a
king and he could do no wrong I love
Wallace I love that he let Scott stay
with him and so Wallace and his two
boyfriends and Scott sleep in the same
bed hilarious we need more Wallace to
all of us do just be better people I
love you guys with the predictions thank
you so much also look at this fan art
that I got on Twitter also gone above I
love it so much thank you so much for
watching see you guys next week bye I'm
just glad I don't have seven
Alexis you punch the highlights out of
my hair
highlight out of my hair
[Music]
[Applause]
you